hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and like most of you I am
getting older when I was your age we
didn't even have podcasts if we wanted
to listen to this American life we had
to turn on the radio and listen to it
coming over the airwaves and that's how
we liked it as a physicist I study the
arrow of time the fact that the past is
different from the future so of course
there is ageing in the sense that we are
all older now chronologically than we
used to be but in the world of biology
there's also aging in the sense that our
bodies are changing as we get older in a
very uniform monotonic way we all had
certain qualities when we were babies
we'll all have certain features and
characteristics when we're elderly and
in between we move from one to the other
in a more or less predictable fashion
but the interesting thing about aging is
that it's not really inevitable in a
sense aging is a choice it's not a
choice that we make as individual
organisms it's a choice that evolution
has made for us if we want to have
evolutionary progress then you have
certain organisms giving birth to others
trying new combinations of DNA
occasional mutations but then the old
ones have to die off they have to give
way to make room for the new generations
aging serves a purpose biologically but
now that we're able to change things a
little bit now that we're able to
manipulate our bodies through medicine
and biology it's come time to ask we
want to keep aging in the same way we
always have
today's guest is dr. Colleen Murphy
she's a professor of molecular biology
at Princeton University and she studies
aging both at the level of organisms and
at the molecular level a favorite
organism is C elegans this is one of the
favorite organisms of all biologists
it's a tiny little round worm and
nematode C elegans and it lives a fairly
quick lifespan so we can play with it we
can mutate it we can turn on and off
different genes inside the round worm we
can see what the effects of this are on
the aging process and interestingly it's
not that
to make a neematoad live much beyond its
ordinary biological lifespan so what are
the consequences of this what are the
implications for human life but we'll
talk about with dr. Murphy is some
implications for what you should do to
live a little bit longer in the
here-and-now and a little bit more
fantastical imaginative things about
whether or not aging is something that
can be completely cured in the very far
future in a more down-to-earth way what
we care about is given that we're going
to age you and I we don't have miracle
drugs to stop that yet can we at least
have more fulfilling energetic aware
lives when we're elderly people do we
necessarily have to undergo the usual
decay and loss of mental faculties that
are associated with being very elderly
again the answer is maybe not this is a
huge direction in which medicine is
moving and fundamental science is
helping along the way so let's go
[Music]
okay calling Murphy welcome to the
podcast
Thanks so we're here at a workshop at
the Santa Fe Institute on time and
Ageing also and you're a biologist by
training who specializes in aging is
that a fair yeah that's correct so how
did you get there how do you choose as
you were just saying before we started
recording a lot of books written on
Aging are written by people who are
themselves aging a little bit so how
does a young researcher decide to pick
this arch I decided when I was a
graduate student I had been doing
studies on pre steady-state kinetics of
myosin so motor proteins and I felt like
I really understood pretty well how to
proteins interact with one another and
how they worked and I felt like I wanted
to start asking bigger questions and
aging is one of the bigger questions you
can ask how does it work and pretty much
everyone's interested in it oh yeah it's
the box office topic right yes exactly
so even though I was fairly young when I
had to get into the field I felt like it
was an interesting question that at that
point actually we've finally had some
really good tools to start addressing
those questions and those tools were
genetics so at that point is right when
especially c.elegans geneticists had
figured out that there were single gene
mutations that could cause doubling of
lifespan so instead of just studying how
things got old you could start asking
the question what's the difference
between something that has a normal
lifespan and one that lives much longer
mm-hm and then another critical point
was that was right win while the C
elegans genome had been recently
sequenced tell us about C elegans
yeah those of us who are not Asian
otto's know this is C elegans is a model
organism so it's a great thing because
biologists of all attitudes and angles
will study this little beastie to death
right that's right so it's one of the
major model systems and it's one it's
one of the great advantage of it is that
it's very simple so it's a simple animal
it's still multicellular so you're
basically instead of working with a
single-celled organism like a yeast
where you can do a lot of wonderful
experiments now you're working with a
real animal that has many tissues and
cells
and one of the advantages just from a
daily experimental perspective is that
when you look through the microscope
down into C elegans you can see that
it's aging right and it's a little worm
about a millimeter it's about a
millimeter long it's some small nematode
it lives in rotting fruit okay
that's work because bacteria will be you
know causing a fruit to rot and so C
elegans will be attracted to that spot
and it'll eat bacteria okay and but you
grow them in Petri dishes lying around
the lab that would be lovely yeah we we
just have them in petri dishes on a you
know standard type of bacteria e.coli
and so that gives us control over its
environment and so while you could
criticize it by saying well that's not
what it does in the natural world it
goes through all these temperature
fluctuations and food fluctuations in
fact what we're modeling I think in the
lab is an American diet so these animals
are always well fed and in air
conditioning basically okay so there
they have the potential to lead long
happy C elegans lives but that's not an
eighty-year-old lifespan right these are
rapidly developing creatures that's
right so these animals go from an egg to
adult in only two days and then that's
when we really start counting for
lifespan so once they become adults who
are capable of reproduction that's sort
of when we start the timer and for that
point they can live an average of two to
three weeks okay so any one population
of animals what's remarkably consistent
actually is the shape of this curve so
you can have a hundred animals and maybe
around day ten some of the one animals
start will die but you know out a day
thirty they'll still be one animal alive
and so that sort of models what we see
in a population where you can have
individuals you have an average lifespan
of the population but you know some
individuals will die seventy and someday
then who died ninety five and so that's
the kind of thing that we're modeling
there I was very affected actually a few
months ago the New York Times had a web
page an app or whatever it was where you
could go in and it's a standard thing
where it computes your life expectancy
so you type in your age and your weight
and your activity level but rather than
just telling you the final number okay
you will
lived to be 78 years old it chose a
random number from the distribution and
said okay in this realization you live
to be 58 before you die and then you do
it again no this time you live to be 102
and yours I was struck very much by the
fact that sort of implicitly we think
you have my lifespan is between 70 and
80 my expected lifespan that's how many
years I have left and the reality is no
I might have relatively few years
there's a relatively high probability
you and there's another probability I
live much longer than that is it the
similar thing for our little round worms
yes absolutely so we have you know in
any one population you have a worm that
if you'd like say on day five they all
look the same it's hard to know it that
day which ones are going to be
long-lived and which ones are gonna be
short-lived and so that's actually one
of the questions we're trying to figure
out what are the things there may be you
know genetic information in this case
there isogenic so they all have the same
genome but there may be for example a
readout in the RNA that they express and
what those that make proteins maybe all
those day five animals if you just were
able to survey them maybe there are some
of those genes that get expressed that
predict which ones will be long-lived in
which things will be short-lived and
that's one of the questions we're
interested in this idea of stochasticity
and aging yeah and if so just to
visualize it a little bit if I was a
grad student in your labs I'm am I
literally there with the traditional
little petri dish a few centimeters
across and with a eyedropper and poking
things around is that I was like
basically yeah you'd have a glass
pipette with a little piece of wire at
the end and you'd be moving them around
and in fact actually now that I'm about
on sabbatical we've been doing a giant
experiment with the whole Lab and so
I've been in their borrowing people's
scopes and moving worms as well it's we
should for the listeners out there not
every professor who's a leader of a lab
spends much time in the lab right this
is a precious yeah to be honest I
haven't either since since I started my
lab one has an army that does you know
things and you're the thought leader
here right and in fact usually when I
for example if someone takes a picture
of my lab I don't let them take a
picture of me at the microscope because
I find it's very misleading right this
is the one exception I've actually been
doing a few experiments but not many it
was the time it's the graduate students
and postdocs are really doing the hard
work
that's right and it's just this has just
always been funny to me but in
theoretical physics where I do things
when people write papers together the
author list is in alphabetical order and
don't understand that right so your name
as the leader of the lab appears last in
the ultimate list right and so that's
this weird reverse priority thing where
you're kind of very important your name
appears last yeah Hank you're pulling
them down and the first author usually
the person who's done most of the actual
you know the labor and often the writing
and hopefully we've all done some of the
intellectual work together right right
often and that's that's the the grad
student in charge of that experiment or
the postdoc or something like that and
so they have the petri dish and then you
are looking in real-time in a microscope
or you videotaping that depends on the
experiment yeah so for we have these
inside they're a little bit laborious a
lot of manual labor involved in some of
the experiments because you're actually
looking at it and making a judgment of
you know by touching the worm is it
still alive or not and then we lock it
down and then we move the live ones
you can't take its pulse right exactly
and so you know there are ways you can
scale that up and lots of labs have so
for example you can do something where
you just take images of plates and we've
done that for a certain purposes yeah
there's other experiments that we take
videos of because we want to know the
nature of their motility or for example
if they're swimming in liquid there's a
really nice wage where you take videos
of them and then you can analyze what's
the shape of their behavior actually and
that's really nice because we actually
discovered recently when we were working
on a Parkinson's project that worms that
had been predicted so this is a
collaboration between my lab and Olga
Tory and Skye's lab we're using these
networks of genes in dopaminergic
neurons in both human neurons and worms
we've got the the network that was
shared between them and that we knew
were expressed in neurons at C elegans
and so and then use that information
with Geo studies so genome-wide
Association studies of Parkinson's
disease okay to try to get a list of new
genes that might play a role in
Parkinson's that no one has discovered
before can
C elegans get Parkinson's disease
without was the question so so we were
wondering could we develop a new model
instead of putting back in for example
alpha-synuclein which is a protein
that's known to accumulate in
Parkinson's disease patients we wondered
whether other genes could participate so
that's what we're looking for like
because it turns out Parkinson's is
caused let me restate that the known
causes of Parkinson's are actually much
more limited than most people realize so
only about 5 to 30 % of Parkinson's
patients how have Parkins is because of
a known gene IC o---- is Parkinson's
something we've identified even in
non-human species well not really that's
what we so that's what I'm getting to
now we were trying to figure out could
we model Parkinson's disease and so if
you just take it at its most basic level
say it's an age-related motor defect
right is there something that we could
find in worms and so that's why we
started these assays where we would
knock down the genes from this list that
were predicted to play some role in
Parkinson's genes Parkinson's disease
and then look at how that changed the
worms swimming behavior so knockdown you
turn off yes gene and so there's a lot
of threads falling off there's a lot of
gin you know details about how how that
is done we just feed the worms actually
bacteria that expresses the RNA of that
gene and it knocks it down through a
process called RNA and interference okay
so we use that and we only did it in
adults because we didn't want to mess up
the development of the neuron in the
first place we really wanted to model
what happens with age if you got rid of
a gene right okay
so doing that and then we just guessed
that you know if we look at age-related
changes in behavior that look different
from what just happens when a worm gets
old
which is what they slow down their
swimming maybe we'll find something
interesting and that turned out to work
remarkably well so it turns out those
worms as for the you know the top set of
genes so we tested 45 genes and the top
20 or so causes weird defect where they
would curl up and we'd never seen that
before so they curl up and uncurl and
they get stuck so that so there's a
whole bunch of genes and you have
of special perfect special-purpose
bacteria yeah there are secret spies
that go into the worm and turn off these
genes and each one of them individually
had the effect that the worm just curled
up in a little ball the top ones did
it's the very top predictions and so
that was we didn't really know what to
look for except for this very generic
idea that there should be some
age-related motility defect but it could
have been something subtle just by
slowing down which is what wild-type
normal worms do when they age but they
had this really different behavior and
so that led us down this path that
became very interesting where we figured
out the branch chain amino acid
metabolism may play a role in
Parkinson's that we hadn't noticed
before and then that caused us to go
back into eventually looking at what
happens if you look at the gene
expression in Parkinson's brains okay
and in several of the areas that are
affected by Parkinson's you see normally
people have high levels of this
particular gene branch chain amino it's
peak at one branch chain amino acid
transferase and it's knocked down in
Parkinson's patients so this is a very
it this all worked better than we had
anticipated but this idea that maybe
there's something that we haven't seen
yet in worms maybe we should just look
and see what happens when we take these
predictions from human diseases and go
into the worm and is this something
obviously one wants to ask is are there
therapies that are suggested or
strategies for treating Parkinson's
based on this connection with individual
that's a great question because what
we're trying to figure out now because
this particular gene can feed into a
couple different metabolic pathways one
important thing for us to figure out is
what part of that pathway which one of
these is it messing up because if you
guess wrong you will cause more problems
so around with human beings in quite the
same way so that's what we're trying to
figure out now and what's interesting
about this is it's not necessarily
predicted that this would have had this
weird phenotype because when other labs
had looked at this particular gene when
they were doing lawn jeopardy studies it
turns out knocking down that same gene
that causes weird curling defect extends
lifespan oh okay so you curl up but you
live longer as a girl that little round
worm exactly so it's kind of a it's a
note of caution right so most of us in
the launc ever
field for a long time have done screens
to look for things to live long my lab
not hasn't it in particular we've always
been interested in this quality of life
effect but I think that's that's what's
really important is to take these ideas
of quality of life with age and ask is
it the same as living a long time sure
and so we had originally done work on
cognitive aging and for the exactly that
purpose this was almost just a surprise
that you could knock down something in
neurons and causes phenotype that in the
rest of the body cause a long lifespan
but it's also you know oh you know I
really want to get that idea out there
that it's important for us to look at
all these measures of quality of life
and not just how long something lives
because I think we already know that as
humans none of us want to live a long
time that's right in a decrepit state
yeah we want to be healthy and so I
think that's actually more important and
it turns out the worms you can actually
use them to study things that we really
care about yeah no I definitely want to
get into this whole idea of different
modes different there seem to be from
your research not one but a set of
different ways which in principle life
could be extended and they have
different side effects and for better
for worse and then we can start asking
questions about which ones matter but
what you just said I think is very
important about we're trying to
extrapolate lessons to higher organisms
by studying these little C elegans so
let's just think into why that's ok like
C elegans one of the things about it as
I understand is that we have mapped out
its entire nervous system it's a 300
some neurons and we know how every one
of them were connected to each other the
connectome of the of the nematode and so
that's very interesting for people
studying the brain in some sense but
there's also the human brain has 85
billion neurons and so that it's hard to
see how exactly to extrapolate so both
from the nervous system but also the
genetic code like how similar are the
genes in C elegans to the genes in
humans how easily can we say oh yes this
thing in that DNA strand plays the same
role in the worm that this gene in our
DNA plays for a person that's a great
question so it depends on what you're
comparing so if you're at the
the tide level I think the estimates
around 60% similarity similarity I mean
C elegans and human being that's right
which is amazing right it is amazing 60%
of the same nucleotide that's DNA
between you know the world and there's
not even that big a difference if you
just count raw gene number that
difference is not so great it's around
19,000 for worms and estimates around
24,000 for humans the number of genes
number of genes now of course that
that's why I think it depends on what
you measure right of course then you
start looking after nobody's least
spliced genes and then sorry you okay
that rapidly so in a gene just for again
it's because I'm not a biologist so we
have DNA and there's many many little
base paired nucleotides we're going to
take that as understood in a gene is
somehow we human beings are associating
a whole length of DNA a whole segment of
it with some function with some ability
to make some kind of proteins and we
call one such part of the DNA strand a
gene is that fair
that's right okay and so we have a not
that many more genes than C elegans does
but we have these wonderful ways of
splitting up a gene in two parts and
then rearranging or inserting different
parts and using them are not using them
now I will say that turns out worms have
that same phenomenon and we have just
been doing an experiment where we take
so worms only have a couple major
tissues they have their skin mm-hmm
they have muscle intestine their nervous
system this is a really major tissue so
my lab figured out how to basically take
adult worms apart and do earn a
sequencing on those and so we can ask
for those large tissues what exactly is
expressed there okay and there's
actually a list of genes that are
differentially alternatively spliced in
each of those tissues as well so even
though we used to think that that was an
explanation for why humans were more
complicated in fact worms do this too so
in the sense that there's one gene but
it kind of plays slightly different
roles depending on which organ it's
talking to exactly for example you can
have an important transcription factor
that is mostly used for metabolic
purposes in the major tissues but it
could be used for a different function
in neurons and so that's the kind of
thing that we're figuring out now and
it's amazingly clever
evolution did all this without any
foresight right without any selection is
a an amazing thing but I was gonna add
to your point about the the number so
this came up at a meeting recently where
someone was discounting the importance
of C elegans based on this argument that
there's has so few cells and humans have
so many but fundamentally what those
cells do at the cell biological level or
at the metabolic level is very well
conserved and so it's just a matter of
you know worms actually may have a
harder job so put this out there okay
they only have 302 neurons yet they
serve a their entire environment and
make decisions about where they should
go what they should eat what's right
they should avoid using only those few
neurons and only about a hundred of them
are our sensory neurons okay and so this
idea you know like if you think about
the mouse olfactory bulb you already
have a neuron where there's a one
receptor for every one of those neurons
right worms don't do that they have many
receptors for every neuron so they're
actually trying to figure out much more
complicated things within each every
single neuron before they can make a
decision now they're they can't
obviously figure out the same level of
things but they do some pretty I think
interesting calculations to try to stay
alive
they have to be pretty efficient in
other words the use of those neurons and
to what extent do we well number one it
was amazing to me to learn that it's
exactly the same number of neurons in
every C elegans and yes it's very very
specific like the DNA has baked into it
quite a detailed blueprint for what that
nervous system is going to look like
exactly and for eating that has some
serious implications which for example
if you think about it like there's this
insulin receptor mutant called daf-2
which lives twice as long as wild-type
it doesn't do that by turning over
getting rid of damaged cells and growing
new ones it has to do it by keeping
those cells healthy the whole lifespan
and so it really changes how you think
about what you can do in order to live a
long time and for us there's some
parallels in the sense that we have some
tissues where you could turn over the
cells and replace them we have other
tissues where you can't do that and so
for those latter sets of tissues that's
what a daf-2 of long-lived animal is a
good model for so what should you do to
keep that cell that you may have your
whole life like a brain cell what would
you have to do to keep that cell alive
and what are the organs and human beings
but
you have the same cells from muscles and
things where you just there's not a lot
of turnover right so there's no way for
that cell to sort of leave and dying be
placed it's there yeah
since we're born or since we should ask
someone who's more of a human geologist
but yeah for some tissues you just can't
replace them they're there though your
whole life or you're at least your whole
adult life and for some you know there's
neuro stem cells but I believe that the
rate of turnover is very low it's so
whereas you have their tissues for
example your blood right you have it's
probably making you wait exactly so
those I don't think I worms at least the
major tissues those aren't are good
they're not a good model for those kinds
of tissues the skin of the roundworms
there forever
exactly Wow so and that actually what we
found out recently that's actually not
just the skin it's actually it's called
the hypodermis it's actually a metabolic
tissue so that's one of the things that
we discovered by tracking whatever you
know every RNA that's made in every
tissue that revealed that to us and we
were able to test that and it's found
out that's true but anyway so worms are
good models for certain types of tissues
and not good models for others since we
keep that in mind the whole time
mm-hmm we do these experiments so let's
let's just allow ourselves since we
brought it up to say a little bit more
about what aging is like in humans and
then go back to the C elegans and get
lessons for how we can change it so what
do we mean when we say a human is aging
right I mean besides the obvious muscle
and memory laws but is it as is it a
known list of things that everyone
agrees this is aging or something that
aging field has come to there's a loss
of homeostasis so tissues that are
trying to remain constant and not lose
ability that gets lost and of course
that manifests in different ways
depending on the tissue so rise and
cardiovascular disease arise and things
like cognitive decline and of course
we've all seen the more superficial ways
you can age like skin wrinkling yeah all
right great here yeah so and it's an
important distinction right because you
could have the idea for example if you
go back to a model system and what
you're tweaking makes the animal better
but if it's the equivalent of you know
changing hair from gray back to black
then you not really changing the entire
so we have to keep those kinds of
differences things that are sort of
fundamental to an organism like keeping
the brain functioning keeping the heart
functioning and separate from things
that are maybe not so important like
wrinkling and you can't see wrinkling or
gray hair in C elegans
oh you can't see right I'd all right
very good so that was my next question
so what do we what are the
characteristics when you're at the
microscope how do you say oh this is an
older worm if you didn't know its
birthday so that's one of the questions
we're asking in the lab because
everybody who's done a lifespan
experiment picks up clue so it's not
it's not just a date so they do some
obvious things they start moving more
slowly and they also sort of lose the
shape of their their trajectory
basically so the younger worms are
better athletes yes and and actually you
Monica Driscoll a Rutgers they've done
studies where they show that um if they
make the animals exercise by forcing
them to swim for a while they actually
live longer oh yeah so they start to get
there's the other skin starts to wrinkle
their muscles get weak which is why they
can't move as well and so and actually
again in Monica Driscoll's lab years ago
Laura Herndon did some nice studies
where they looked at the whole body
different tissues by e/m and they see
sarcopenia so the degradation of muscle
tissue just like in humans right okay um
the neuromuscular Junction starts to
degrade and that's actually why they
start to slow down first so Shawn shoes
lab showed that years ago and what we've
found is that the thing that precedes
all of those is their inability to they
start losing the ability to learn and
more important they start before that
they've lost their ability to long term
memory so there's a sort of a I don't
know if it's a cascade but you can
certainly say there's a different
trajectory for different behaviors so
the most complicated thing that we find
that their worms do is this long-term
memory right they lose that by day four
of adulthood later they lose the ability
to learn and do short-term memory and
then they lose the ability to smell
after that which is what's required for
all of those other activities and
after that well after that they lose the
ability to move so there's a period
where they you know you can imagine a
middle-aged worm they can't remember
anymore maybe can't learn it can still
smell stuff but it might not yeah and it
can move yeah exactly so yeah so they
don't it's not like they'll crash at the
same time and I think that's sort of
what we see in humans right certainly
roughly analogous yeah exactly
I can't you know run hurdles anymore
like I did when I was 16 I can still do
calculations I may not be able to do
certain things and there's gonna be
things in the future that I won't be
able to do so so number one though C
elegans can learn and have things in
long-term memory how do we know that so
learning that was established by some
other labs early on and they can do
things like negative associations so if
you starve a worm and let it smell a
chemical then later on when it smells
that chemical it will avoid it so we
were interested in asking the question a
little bit differently a more analogous
to what we might be interested in when
we learn information so my lab started
doing assays where we paired food with a
neutral odor called butanone and the
idea was that even if so a worm we knew
they could smell the butanone but they
wouldn't like the smell they wouldn't go
toward that odor until we'd done the
training where they pair food with buna
okay so that lovin is dog exactly
training and so that's simple learning
and then we ask the question how long do
they remember that so after we did the
training we put the worms back onto
plates with food but no odor and asked
how long do they retain that and I'm
within two hours they've forgotten that
I trained that once okay right so
everyone thinks that sounds like a short
time but a couple of things so if you
are a worm in the world maybe it's not
worth remembering something longer than
that if that food source is not going to
be there anymore and the other thing is
I think it might be analogous to you
know if I gave you a ten digit number
and I asked you three hours later you
might not remember it and two hours is a
much larger chunk of the worms lifespan
than three hours is for us exactly so
then and this was inspired by work that
had been done in other organisms like
Drosophila we did space training so he
would train the worms and then give them
a rest and train them again and we found
that if we
that and we trained them for example
seven times then the next day we could
come back and they would still remember
and that turns on a different set of
molecules actually it turned on you know
the earlier learning I told you about is
pretty instantaneous and it can require
protein translation as well but if we
want to do long-term memory that turns
on a transcription factor you get theta
it's the signal this is worth
remembering if you hit it enough times
okay and it turns on this transcription
factor called cred and that that turns
on a whole set of genes that we later
figured out by using the same technique
RNA I'm knocking them down that if we
knock those out memory is totally wiped
out and are those memories stored in the
302 neurons yeah so that CREB
transcription factor is only active in
one pair of neurons okay so that's
basically the worms hippocampus so you
get two neurons remember things exactly
and they must send we haven't figured
this out entirely but they must send a
signal back to that sensory neuron to
tell the words when they smell that
butanone again what they should do that
they should still like it
it's amazing the similarities between
our 885 billion neuron brand and you can
identify structures in the 300 neuron
brain is a little worm
doing the same thing acid don't be
fooled by the 302 neurons it almost
makes you believe in evolution right we
just didn't get things from scratch that
core set of you know proteins and genes
that are used by every organism to carry
out these these tasks so we have an
aging worm hmm so and you said the signs
of aging start a few days well certainly
they lose our memory at a point when it
would be difficult to tell by eye that
they're there anyway so that starts
pretty very sort of the first thing to
go yeah and I think that coincides
pretty well with the end of their
reproductive time they make sense why do
they need to remember anything that's
because I need to figure out where food
is and then they don't worry exists well
actually
so for hermaphrodites they're doing
their best to avoid males they actually
will run away from them right because
almost all C elegans are females yeah so
this exactly so say a thousand to one
hermaphrodites two males and so they
don't really need the males until they
do so the times when they would need
them is
there you know it's times when they need
some genetic diversity so in times of
stress and they've figured that out too
when times of stress they start the
mothers will a more male eggs by losing
a chromosome and then those males will
mate with the hermaphrodite and 50% of
their progeny will now be males yeah
because every cuz they're basically when
they mate that's the chromosomes would
be either xx or XO so 50% of them will
be hermaphrodites and 50% will be males
and so you can get these you know bursts
of meals and hermaphrodites in the
realization exactly yeah
so I said females but it's really
hermaphrodites before C elegans right
for C elegans the worms that are not
males can play the role of male or
female but they are only carrying their
own genetic information so like you say
if you want a little bit of diversity is
there a lot of diversity in the genome
of C elegans I am NOT the best person to
answer that there are a lot of people
were asking questions like that and and
also asking for like natural isolates of
C elegans what kind of level of
diversity is I want to say yes okay
alright so you have all these from
Aphrodite the occasional dude around
there and so you don't need to work hard
to find sexual partners right but you do
need to work hard to find food and
that's pretty much all that C elegans
character that's right his food yeah
that's right and so you're saying that
it makes sense that if you have a
reproductive lifespan which is what
about half of the total span yeah that
once you've reached that point your
faculties begin failing you for various
reasons and memory is one of the first
ones to go exactly so I think that makes
sense and because you don't those
animals don't need to find food anymore
the pressure is not so great if they so
there's no pressure to keep that
maintained and I think it's actually
probably a lot of work because that
long-term memory machinery is very
complicated and this was a surprise to
me because earlier when I done the work
to identify the genes downstream of the
longevity pathway the daf-2 insulin
signaling pathway we found that there
were hundreds of genes turned on and
when I knocked down those using RNAi I
each gene that we lost only had about
five or maximum 10% effect on lifespan
so that's a very cumulative process you
have to do a bunch of different many
genes or in fact
it was different when my lab started
doing the knockdown of the genes that
describe transcription factor regulates
when we knocked on any of those they
seem to screw up memory so it's more of
a machine where you lose a part and now
it all falls apart and so that I think
would take a lot more energy an effort
to maintain in a pristine state not a
collective effort it's this gizmo better
be working pretty exact thing and so I
think that's why it's one of the first
things to fall apart right and it's
interesting just to think that evolution
does not select for longevity right
longevity is is backwards right because
you want to have kids and then as far as
the population is concerned you're not
only not helpful you're in the way in
some sense and so the fact that and
maybe this has lessons for human beings
the fact that there is a lifespan and
that we're supposed to die is not a
mistake it's what the organism evolves
to do it might be now I don't know if
they're really in the way because old
worms don't eat anything and they have
so many more progeny that probably one
adult being around 300 progeny is not
gonna make much of a dent so I think of
it's more that there's no pressure to
maintain its life its health anymore
right and so the only maintenance that
it really is invested in is to be able
to be reproductive long enough to get
its job done to make more progeny and it
is subtle because you might imagine that
if one particular individual had a
genetic code that let it live a long
time and have many many more progeny
than its competitors that would be
beneficial to it and it's and it's a
bloodline as it were but the population
would suffer because the genetic
diversity would be diminished by that
one dominant and that's well I think
we'd that maybe what we have is
wild-type that basically it got to the
maximum number of progeny could have and
lifespan it could have and still do
everything right because the long-lived
mutants none of them have as many
progeny okay okay so there's a reason
there's mutant wild-type wild-type
someone all these other situations and
it has this flexibility it can respond
to differences in environment
and when we get a mutant in the lab
really what we are looking at something
that's locked into one state and so in
the wild it wouldn't survive as well
because it can't respond properly okay
so yeah so tell us a little bit more
let's go through the different ways that
we can make our c elegans live longer so
there's this def - I know plays a big
role so no one knows what f2 is yeah
it's called daf-2 because it was found
in the very early studies when people
were looking at development but it turns
out that you can knock down this gene
just in adults you don't have to screw
up development at all and still get this
effective a long long life and that's
really important an important
distinction because the fact that this
insulin receptor was found to live long
a long time I think people discounted it
in the aging field longer than they
should have because it has this other
role in our formation and it was easy to
say well that's just a weird worm thing
and our is this weird sort of
hibernation stage you can go in -
exactly so C elegans has a lot of lovely
ways to be able to avoid disappearing
and so in times of really really
stressful conditions it will go into
this alternative developmental state
called our now and that's regulated by
temperature and food and crowding
conditions so but again if we go back to
def - you don't have to do that you
don't have to go through that state in
order to live a long time and this was
shown by Andy Dillon when he was in
Cynthia canyons lab that if you use our
own AI to knock down daf-2 justin adults
those weren't a little a long time and
so and it also doesn't have to be in
that case it wasn't coupled to
reproduction but in the wild of course
all these changes that would allow an
animal to live a long time or cause it
to live a long time like reducing the
amount of food that it has or so dieting
works well to extend the life they are
do and dieting perfectly well for C
elegans that's right and so um but of
course all of those will cause the
animal to have fewer progeny right okay
so you can live longer but you're less
genetically useful and so the daf-2
that's a gene yes and you knock it out
and the worm lives longer but it also
has fewer progeny is that yeah so if you
knocked out for its whole life the
mutant has fewer progeny okay and that's
also true of worms that are either color
clear restricted or you have a mutant
that mimics that state because it can't
chew it
properly right okay so all of those so
those are two different ways and
actually and there's something called
intermittent fasting which probably
everyone has heard about yes worms will
live longer as well through intermittent
fasting but that turns out to act using
that same daf-2 insulin signaling FOXO
transcription factor pathway so other
than not reproducing as much what is it
that daf-2 does do the worm to make it
live longer oh well that's what we found
when we did the so when I was a postdoc
and I built microarrays to try to
identify all the genes that were
different between the long lived animals
and the short lived animals that's what
we figured out so we identified the set
of genes that were different and it
wasn't just oxidative stress reduction
it was a lot of things so um it changed
lipid metabolism it changes they say
that was you know we started looking at
produce stasis keeping proteins healthy
basically if you made a list of
everything you need to do to make a cell
work better or stay healthy without
turning over that's what basically the
death to does turns on all these genes
involved in things like atif oh gee but
sorry i'm getting confused because
turning off death to make you live
longer okay sorry so this is an internet
it's a little bit hard to explain so the
insulin receptor you can think of it as
when the in select the insulin receptor
the staff to is on high that signal of
high food okay okay and it thinks
there's a lot of food around when though
animals think there's a lot of food
around the right thing to do is to have
as many prodding as you can and you
don't care how long you live okay okay
so when you get a signal there's not
much food that means not much insulin
that means less death to activity right
and the response to that is turning on a
transcription factor called daf-16 which
is in this family of transcription
factors called FOXO and that was found
later in mice and now in centenarians
studies to also be involved in longevity
in mammals so in some sense the pace of
life slows down yes so you live longer
but more slowly and less enjoyably when
these conditions are mmm less enjoyably
I don't know daf-2 animals look awesome
right so they don't slow down they don't
well okay that's emotion
that's an interesting question so a lot
of labs have looked at just how animals
will move on a plate okay and so if you
just do that daft you animals look like
they're less healthy by that definition
but they're not they're actually super
healthy because if you touch them they
can sprint off I see so by deaf do we
mean the ones we're deaf to is turned
off
yeah so they're the mutant sorry it's
very but they're the long lived animals
right so it's not that they can't move
they just choose not to and my lab
figured out why that is because we
thought that was really weird because
people were going around saying oh
Daphne's not healthy when every metric
we could every every asset we threw at
them they did better and so what we
figured out was that daf-2 animals have
a higher level of a receptor called odor
10 and another lab had shown already
that odor 10 levels were super low in
males okay so the reason this is
important is because it got me thinking
and there was a great this is Doug
Portman's lab and he had a great paper
we showed this this difference in males
in this particular gene and when he put
more of this odor 10 gene back into
males they made it less well okay and
that was because they didn't start it
they weren't exploring anymore so low
levels of odor 10 cause an animal to
explore more and high levels think it's
food and so the headline of that you
know the sort of pop headline was males
choose sex over food okay and that was
all through the odor tan gene and so
what we figured out was daf-2 has very
high levels of this and said they're
really choosing food right okay and so
what we did was we used RNA I again to
knock it down and found out when you do
that but daf-2 worms are crawling and
they never stop oh there's still keep
running around they are totally capable
of moving they just choose not to
because they're sitting on food they
know there's food they're gonna eat the
food so anyway that was it's an
important point in my field because
there is a mistaken notion the daf-2
worms were unhealthy for a while so they
live longer but less healthily and
you're saying that in fact they're
perfectly healthy they think there's
lots of food so they don't see the need
to exert themselves that's exactly right
and so I would say that's so deaf to
worms are like that there are other
longevity means that are not health
and so it is worth thinking about this
idea as we mentioned before that not
everything that lives a long time is
going to be healthy and so we and others
did some quality assays we found that
for example there's long-lived mutants
for that have knocked down their
mitochondrial function okay and those
are being studied for a lot of good
reasons but if you look at the mutants
in C elegans they are not healthy okay
so they're not a good model and they
also you have to knock down the
mitochondrial function again this is
again Andy Dylan's work when he was a
postdoc in Cynthia's lab if you you have
to knock it down in larval stages to get
this result so but very young yeah yeah
so the the human equivalent of these
saying give you know give teenagers or
adolescents a drug that will stunt their
growth yeah make them non reproductive
and then but they'll live a long time
right right so that's not a model of
good longevity it's not a goal clearly
but so lesser mitochondrial function
less energy is going to our tissues our
muscles we're just gonna be sluggish
yeah and then we'll live a long time
without even being able to move unlike
the deaf - exactly so that's why we
really like the daf-2 model because it
really mimics something that we can sort
of identify with if we're gonna
anthropomorphic heights anything it's
that we are that daf-2 worms are kind of
the model of what we'd like to do in
humans so it's worth knowing what they
do and also ask any question can we have
this effect post reproductively right
because that's a critical point like if
everything you have to do you have to
modify while the animal including us is
reproductive then it's not gonna do us
much good when we finally get interested
in taking a drug for aging so that's
what we need to figure out so how much
can we extrapolate from the ability to
knock out deaf - and have happy
longer-lived
worms - any lessons for human beings
um I think understanding what the
molecular components are that change and
those long lived animals is really
instructive and then doing the actual
experiments to ask the question well how
late can we do that my my labs not doing
work in other organisms right now but
people who work with mice are starting
to ask that question how late can we
have an intervention because if you have
to do it the whole life that's not
practical but if you can find
interventions like a deaf - equivalent
knocking down that receptor or something
equivalent late in life then that starts
to be something that's useful for asking
the question can we keep people
healthier right and then you know like
what I was talking about Parkinson's
there are things that we would want to
knock down or sorry or effect in to
improve cognitive function and we have
to know how is that gonna affect
longevity and vice versa if we have a
longevity treatment how is that gonna
affect cognitive functions right so
asking those questions first and a
really tractable organism like C elegans
is very helpful so you can sort of
untangle all those things and it seems
to take an optimistic lesson from it
there's nothing biologically certainly
there's nothing in the laws of physics
but even biologically there's nothing
wrong with really repairing our cells to
keep them going it's just if I may
extrapolate so correct me if I'm going
crazy it's just that our biology chooses
not to do that because we've outlived
our usefulness I think that's basically
right but we could easily imagine
therapies treatments whatever that tell
our bodies no actually keep those cells
healthy for another thousand years
exactly and some mild forms of stress
this idea of hormesis where you have a
mild stress and that turns on our stress
response and that in the end makes an
animal live longer you know that's a
kind of thing that you know intermittent
fasting or caloric restriction or some
of these drugs might be doing so telling
your cells there's not enough food let's
turn on the stress response that
actually could be good right right yeah
so this is I think that this I've heard
this kind of discussion in the context
of diets that somehow making your body
think that things are going bad is good
for it because that's when it's
self-preservation mechanisms kick in a
little bit like the body gets a little
bit complacent if you just feed it
healthy food all the time and that can
actually have bad effect that's right so
you want more than each a kind of thing
really whatever doesn't kill you makes
you live long and that's actually true
for the worm so you give them a little
bit of heat stress or a little bit of
metabolic stress or don't feed them a
little while and then they will you just
the trick is you don't want to do it to
them of course right so none of this
gives us worms that live forever no but
if you add the pathways together so as a
nice study that again Cynthia's lab did
years ago where they took I really was
germline so worms that have lacked the
germ-line because that's another
mechanism to extend lifespan and then I
think of as they also knocked down the
daf-2 receptor anyway they got worms
that lived something like 114 days oh
wow as opposed to 14 days yes so and at
the end the student who was doing the
work actually named the worms attached
yeah so and then there's a mutant in
that same insensitively pathway there's
a gene just the protein acts just
downstream of death to the receptor
where there are mutation that if they
can get it through coax them through
development then those animals live ten
times as long Wow so it just means that
they're turning on these repair pathways
on hi now I don't they probably don't
have any progeny they can't get through
developments they have other problems
but it does suggest that if we knew the
molecular tricks to do to the cells you
could do this right of course it becomes
you know more complicated with humans
with way more tissues no of course but I
get the the lesson seems to be that
there's individual things that point us
in the right direction and interesting
combinations of these individual things
don't just add they really reinforce
each other in positive ways yeah and I'm
excited about the idea of exercise
because that's in humans it seems like
it just helps with everything so you
could argue there you might give
somebody a drug that it would extend
lifespan but it may not help their
cognitive function or vice-versa but
there are some things that seem to help
everything and I think that's where
we're gonna that seems like a more
logical way to go is to try to find the
things that will help the entire system
right and there's sort of short-term
strategies for people alive right now
exercise good maybe intermittent fasting
is helpful probably good diet is helpful
mental activity is that something well
that's my interesting so my colleague
Sam long has done some work on this who
says that that's all baloney yeah it
could be
so these brain games type of thing it
seems more the idea of exercise and
things that help with cardiovascular
activity too that actually helps more so
there's an analogy that would make you
think exercising your brain and makes it
a stronger muscle but maybe that's all
just nonsense right it turned out it
just makes people really good at that
type of crossword puzzle right in itself
if you're really just fine right an
actual exercise though
might be cardiovascular health will help
your cognitive fashions a little bit and
as it turns out some of the I was just
reading about study yesterday's we're
using muscles to keep not just
cardiovascular health the actual
strength higher is good because then it
turns out those because of this
mitochondrial we haven't talked about
this yet but the mitochondria actually
talked to each other through signals
called my to kinds and so when there is
mitochondrial stress in one place it can
signal to other tissues that there's
their stress as well and turn on this
response and so this idea is that if you
keep your muscles healthy they may
actually be sending out more than just
you know just this cardiovascular
activity may be actually telling your
other cells to improve their
mitochondrial function okay good those
teamwork amongst the cells telling them
to live a long time so have we missed
any different mechanisms for making our
c elegans live longer
well interrupting their reproduction
helps them don't have kids intermittent
fasting exercise I think that's the main
ones but they're all things that we can
kind of relate to yeah they are things
we communicate to and and actually it's
not just we can sit around waiting for
the miracle drug these are things that
we can imagine doing yeah and I think
you should still have kids is there any
data on human beings do childless people
live longer so there's a study that gets
quoted most often to this point and
there's a study about Korean eunuchs and
those men live longer than their cohort
okay so men and women well this was only
a study at this you know that's like
Palace yeah so I think it sounds like
they'll be very hard to control for an
enormous Li large other number of
factors I don't really buy that one but
it wouldn't seem to be that hard to just
ask you know demographically do
childless people well I don't think it's
childless it's does your germline not
function okay
and in that case like if a germline
doesn't function there could be other
sort of diseases or other you know
problems that it's not so I'm not sure
that that's actually the right question
ask but you could ask whether there are
certain hormones associated with the
germline that are ProHealth or ant
and you so right now there's an upper
limit to how human beings live 120 years
something like that
yeah the longest living person that we
know about lived 122 years 120 years and
were they with it at the end do you know
I don't know I mean the reports make it
seem like she was but I don't don't
actually get the reliability of that
might be there might be a story you want
to tell that is that yeah I I do know
that you know there's some debate about
what the actual upper limit is on the
study that sort of addressed this the
problem was that woman was she no she's
an outlier point and sort of changed the
curve and so she wasn't their beacon
they would give us the impression that
it continues to increase right and all
the time like right now the oldest
living human is usually around 100 1516
something like that but you know it
doesn't mean I mean there's ever more
super sentient those are super
centenarians and there's more and more
people who live that long so it suggests
that that won't be the upper limit soon
and also the the different things we
were talking about in terms of diet and
exercise is it safe to say that they
improved the quality of life when we're
in our upper years not just the number
of years yeah I would I would say that
really those things do improve quality
of life I do want to make an extinction
a distinction between these super
centenarians and what we're talking
about right I think the rest of us are
mere mortals right we mortals exactly
and I think that the centenarians and
certainly the super centenarians they
may be people who just through genetic
luck are impervious to all those damages
that other people so you know if you
know if I were to smoke or do all these
things it would probably cause me to
live shorter definitely would make me
live shorter it's not clear that that's
true for the super centenarians so
that's the other question asks like what
is different about this population
because the funny thing is I've started
collecting these stories about you know
because people always interview them and
ask this question what do you do that
makes you live so long and they always
have an explanation and for about 70% of
women the answer is I stayed away from
men but they always say you know and
there's things like I you know I drink a
glass of whiskey every day or have two
boiled eggs and of course that's you
know ludicrous and I'm one but I think
it doesn't matter what
Yeah right most of them drink and a lot
of them smoked because that was a thing
and I think it didn't matter but for us
the rest of us we have to take care of
our bodies a little bit better they were
born on third base tanned think that the
and but from everything that you've been
saying that there's things we as
individuals can do to live a little bit
longer a little bit healthier etc but
there's also we can let our imaginations
run about therapies and drugs and
treatments in the future I'm not going
to say when maybe you'll say when but
that could extend lifespan more or less
indefinitely in principle there are
certainly people who are working on
those kinds of things and they have
taken it to the point where they're
actually developing drugs to do things
like get rid of senescence cells because
senescence cells for example are very
toxic to the rest of the body so those
kinds of drugs likes analytics or
activate the tiny kind of metabolism
that we're talking about in daf-2 worms
you know turning on those pathways
basically tricking the bodies into
thinking that your calorically
restricted right and doing all those
things yourself but exactly so and then
there's this idea right so that you
could take certain drugs that are
already being used for other diseases
and those are helping people live longer
beyond what they were expecting with
just fixing that disease so that you
know that's the idea behind metformin
for example now I'm not involved in any
of those studies I'm more interested in
the question of like what is quality of
life can really improve that and can we
model it and can we figure out what the
molecular components that help us
improve quality of life and hopefully
those things will extrapolate as well
can we be extrapolating enough to say
that the 21st century is last century
that human beings will be dying of old
age maybe if they're rich enough yeah
well that's the whole thing right I mean
what if there's a therapy that says oh
you can live for a thousand years it
costs a million dollars that there's a
social problem that comes up very very
strongly right there right and I think
that is part of the thinking among some
of the people who are who are doing some
of the work not the not doing the
science but but I think we have to get
away from that because that's already
true you know if we think about the way
people get treated for other diseases
like cancer sadly because the way our
healthcare system still works you have a
better
chance of living if you're rich then if
you're poor right and so I think that
anti-aging drugs are Pro longevity drugs
those would be things that would sort of
be the extreme of that situation yeah I
think it will become a lot more vivid
when people do start the rich people do
start living a lot longer and that'll be
something I don't know it'll be very
interesting I'm not quite sure what will
actually happen I'm very bad at
predicting these political changes so
far you know it rattles around in the
brain when you're working on some of
these things like what are the
ramifications of that in general what we
really hope though is that if you were
to find something that every person
could take would be relatively
inexpensive and it would just help them
avoid something like cardiovascular
disease or diabetes or all these
metabolic syndromes that people develop
in developed countries with age that
would be something that really would
help all of us be healthier and live you
know maybe not hugely longer but
somewhat longer but with higher quality
of life right so that's really what
we're going for at least those those of
us who work on the things that we do I
know that that other training you know
other thought is that you can have
somebody live right I just I'm not sure
that well book ever get there and I'm
not so sad that that would be the case
yeah and I think that's okay I just
wanted to sort of let ourselves go while
but I think that you're right that it
seems sensible team's reasonable to
imagine that it's not that will go
exactly as we are now and then someone
will discover an immortality drug is
that along the way we'll learn to fix
some of the problems knock out some of
the worst things that will make us
healthier for longer exactly and I think
the biggest area where we need to think
about that as cognitive decline right
right because now people are living long
enough that they are developing and
dementia and things that at a rate that
people didn't have before simply because
they didn't live long enough to get them
and so that's what we really have to
figure out now is how to avoid how can
we really treat Alzheimer's disease and
other things like that the really impact
quality of life in a way that's beyond
just you know like I've run slower right
and you don't to help people be
functional tilt until the end of their
lives and I think that's really where
the major focus is going to be
but it sounds us from everything you
said so far that there's grounds for
optimism I mean on some timescale it's
always hard to predict how quickly
things happen but these are not
intractable problems they're not we have
to do a better job of identifying the
cause of some of those problems and
Alzheimer's is really I think the big
one because you know that's just right
the longer we may have people live
eventually if we don't figure out that
problem they could be walking around
just fine but getting Alzheimer's so
it's those seem to be the relationship
between that longevity and Alzheimer's
is not entirely clear to us and so I
think we have to work on that while we
work on these other quality of life
issues as well but that's really a big
one and meanwhile I can't let you quite
get away without raising this other
issue that you ran into over the course
of your investigations about you know
because you're studying reproduction
obviously plays a large role in this
lifespan issue and so what gets passed
down to different generations of the
worms you're studying and you came
across a little bit of a surprise is
that right yeah so talk about it will or
is it a butyl mummy okay so yes I mean
by the way so it's not that you can't
talk about it because it's bad instead
you know we don't want it to get out
there before it's published exactly and
also we don't know the whole mechanism
yet right so we just know this
phenomenon that we discovered recently
that when the worms encounter a pathogen
which actually I really initially like
it's like I think it smells like
hamburgers or something to them they
love it if you start eating it but it's
bad for them and it makes them sick
and so other people had figured that out
already so Cori Bargmann lab and young
giant already figured out that when they
eat this Pseudomonas bacteria that they
then feel sick and they later know to
avoid it and so that's the way we
consider the mothers doing that and
that's learning we've already said
learning they can learn these things
yeah so that's all factory learning and
so what we recently discovered sort of
kind of because we were looking for it
but a little bit accidentally that these
analysts pass that information on down
to their progeny so they their kids
already know to avoid Pseudomonas even
though they've never seen it before and
they certainly haven't eaten it and got
sick from it so it's basically like if
my mom had gotten food poisoning and
then for them from there on out I could
ever eat that food again potato salad or
something is it was the food poisoning
or what the the negative stimulus before
they even had the children well that's
what we started asking next because you
could have reasoned like so in the case
of my mom if she had that a potato salad
I made her sick while she was pregnant
with me then that's kind of one
phenomenon that's different from if you
know she ate it and then 20 years later
had me right yes and so we asked that by
asking how many generations do these
worms know to avoid Pseudomonas and so
far it's out to like the great great
granddaughters is it possible they're
being taught did they go to little C
elegans school sites avoid this stuff or
it must be already passed down to them
their neurons already know to neurons
now and is it I think that this leads us
to this issue that we have a cartoon of
how inheritance works that we get from
high school biology there's a code
there's a DNA and there's a set of base
pairs and there's a information encoded
there and that's what we passed down but
in fact where it's increasingly becoming
clear that more than that gets passed
down there are other chemicals that go
along when you give birth to somebody
and information can somehow be encoded
in there is that probably what's going
on in this yeah we think it's probably
modifying that DNA though if I did DNA
directly I just let means we don't think
it's modifying the DNA we think it's
modifying the structures that protect
the DNA histones so these chromatin so
we think that's part of it and there may
be other factors as well but we start to
figure it out so we'll know soon but
there is you know there are enzymes that
do the job of doing these modifications
and undoing them so the idea is you
could rewrite this what's called histone
code we don't really know yet and so
we'll try to figure that out but it
could be something else but there are
memories being passed down and it's not
just the DNA but you're born knowing
something yeah cuz your great-grandma
learned it yeah so this is still blowing
my mind this out if it's true I think it
should but I think that we're onto
something and it would make sense for
these worms because if they encounter a
specific pathogen it may be worth
remembering it I don't know whether you
want really weird questions why don't
they just
always avoid it and so I don't know if
this pathogen smells like something else
that's normally nutritious for them
right but it's there in their
environment and they have to know not to
eat it or maybe eating a little bit it's
not terrible and it's a good reminder
that even if you knew the entire genetic
code of the organism you don't know the
whole organism that's right because
there's more things in life than than
our DNA yeah nature is fascinating we're
still trying to figure out everything
out and all that know Colleen Murphy
thanks so much for coming
[Music]
you
[Music]